je suis en banlieue parisienne à la
rencontre de fred de ville qui est
dessinateur auteur de bande dessinée il
est aussi rescapé du bataclan et c'était
un sujet qui infuse son oeuvre récente
bonjour fred merci de nous accueillir
merci bonjour
au lit alors faites vous dessinez tous
les jours vous dessinez des choses qui
ont trait à l'expérience traumatique que
vous avez vécu
l'expérience traumatique ou
comme certains disent à la résilience
aux débuts chez nous les tout premiers
dessins que je faisais c'était vraiment
les deux les dessins de l'attak et que
de latin qui est des trucs complètement
pour moi ingérable et puis au fur et à
mesure du temps je suis passé de plus en
plus dans des allégories
la c3 on va dire trois morts
qui tentent de murray a tiré vers le
fond d'un océan
c'est un peu la veille du procès en fait
j'avais eu cette idée là ça représentait
assez bien
ma crainte par rapport au procès qui
était que le procès mme rey emmène vers
le bas avec des choses que je pouvais
apprendre avec le fait de remuer tout ça
encore une fois même si on aime you
toujours dedans
elisa on sait
tous les deux la main elle était blessé
j'avais voulu l'aider sans voir qui a
été blessé et puis bah du coup je
pouvais plus sortir les le couloir était
complètement vide
et je me suis allongé dans le sens d'un
gamin qui était juste à côté de nous qui
étaient décédées et on a passé les deux
heures quasiment main dans la main lisa
et moi
à se tenir
compagnie à soutenir le moral
l'utilité qu'à mes livres et le fait que
mes livres fasse du bien des gens me
donnent un rôle social me font du bien
la tête par rapport à tout ça mais de se
séparer de l'horreur que j'ai vécu je
sais pas si si un jour ce sera fini et
si je réussirai par ce biais là à mon
passé je suis encore
suivi je suis encore sous traitement
je suis pas du tout pour le moment
incapable de m'en passer je suis encore
je suis encore en état de stress
facilement d'une manière qui nécessite
une thérapie et oui ça c'est évident
j'ai toujours pas récupéré une vie
normale j'ai toujours pas récupéré un
sommeil normal j'ai toujours pas
récupéré une
une capacité à sortir et à faire des
choses normalement finalement les gens
que je côtoie maintenant sont quasiment
tout le temps des victimes donc on se
comprend très bien entre nous on sait
très bien de quoi on parle on sait très
bien
ce que l'on vit et ce que n'ont recensé
par ce soutien là général entre nous je
pense qu'on a réussi à tenir si on
n'avait pas eu ça je sais pas comment
est ce qu'on aurait fait
les combats
on s'est retrouvé plongé
dans un massacre
nationale c'est
pas l'état n'est pas directement
responsable
n'empêche que c'est le rôle de l'état de
prendre en charge ces citoyens dans ce
genre de situation et de les prendre
correctement en charge du début à la fin
je veux dire on aurait on ne devrait pas
avoir à se battre pour être indemnisés
pour avoir les supports qu'on doit avoir
on devrait pas se battre pour courir
après le bon chirurgien ou le bond de
six colonnes après diana
difficultés que rencontrent les
survivants celle après le parcours
administratif par exemple c'est moi qui
ai dû faire toutes les démarches c'est
moi qui ai dû me battre pour pour tous
là je me suis fait aider parce que je
pouvais plus du tout le fond de garantie
c'est un truc extraordinaire et c'est
extraordinaire que c était que c était
créé mais celle
la pro activité qui n'est pas là pour
ceux qui se retrouvaient dans une
terrasse et qui ont été miraculeusement
vivant au milieu de tous ces morts pour
ceux qui étaient dans la salle pour ce
qu'ils étaient je veux dire surtout les
six ce qui a été vu il suffisamment
marquants pour qu'on puisse avoir
l'idée que l'on va il pris en mains
correctement le fonds de garantie me dit
mais vous dessinez toute la journée donc
tôt finalement vous êtes capable de
travailler
si justo complètement délirant
alors faites vous allez sortir un
nouveau livre nouvelle bd dans laquelle
vous parler de cette fois de résidence
j'ai réalisé après coup que c'était de
la résilience parce que pour moi c'était
simplement
ces dernières années dont je parlais et
puis le combat que c'est
bon ça s'appelle conversation avec ma
mort donc c'est assez clair du type de
combat j'espère le finir sur une note
positive puisque je dirige vers la vie
en tout temps la mort c'est à dire que
c'est gagné mais enfin que j'essaye en
tout cas de gagner le combat